well basically I see many games off all
intermediate players or even a little
bit more than that and quite a bit
calculating or very very precise
calculating is something that I see well
pretty much each one does it to its own
level but what I want to get done today
is to look at enough position and get a
feeling of when we should stop
calculating I mean which lines should we
calculate and when we should stop
calculating in any given position and
the best thing actually to practice it
is just to basically do some puzzles or
something like that which is what we're
going to do today okay so this is the
position in white to play and actually
it's interesting though well the idea is
quite obvious but there are two ways to
achieve it
yes seriously
okay and if I take and if I move the
king and if I take dude like I caught of
dad ah no but that's exactly why we have
gathered here today no Alexis yeah look
tanks now we're going to see this in a
second you know from some weak moment of
I don't know mercy and being nice I
haven't mentioned your name so the
billions of people are going to watch it
on YouTube another but after the show
bending we're going to leave your
address and email phone everything so
people can bother you know but this is
winning no depend upon wants to promote
of course oak GA t' actually you don't
even have to I mean okay you can just
just promote take take I don't somehow
win here in great style
just bring the cane and that's it like
blacking blacking cannot cannot approach
the pawn white as an extra piece right
he's going to win this pawn and make a
queen one day as opposed to Julian here
sitting just in front of me looking at
the camera big smile no like this seven
and you are not going to win this one
right so we're going to think better but
this exactly is the thing when we see an
idea okay the idea is to push the pawn
make it a queen whatever
I agree okay next one okay
we'll flip the ball like is to play here
now this is actually a very very decent
one like just there are several pieces
that are hanging right I mean the bishop
on f1 can be captured the knight on d5
the knight on f6 okay bit huh
so what do we do
okay black black would like to take
black would like to win some material
somehow but the question is how to take
on f1 right I mean because there are
pieces that are hanging so the question
is how to take this Bishop let's start
with the most actually natural capture
right
Luke takes if one rook takes Bishop
takes and then Knight capture on f6
right why does it choice why doesn't
have to automatically capture the bishop
which is going to lose just going to be
a knight down so the capture capture mmm
no big problems actually fall black you
actually which move black will play here
he has to take the two pawn right I mean
of course the pawn endgame is just
losing nothing to see yeah maybe maybe
black is actually better here still
because we will win this pawn in night
will be notoriously horrible defending
against outside passed pawns here this
is still better public do you hear hear
attacking this pawn black will take here
but all these could have been prevented
first bishop take Julian's proudest
moment
no because that's that's a big thing if
Luke takes if one is before Luke take
with a check check
so basically White has to capture in
this way because if it takes here black
is not going to take the night but we'll
play check so that process of thinking
when there are many captures it's quite
basic but important because just any any
other wrong sequence but why it would be
alive okay well let's do now one that is
I think more challenging okay
white is to play no but here we need to
see exactly and not to speak
27 and why is the smooth make sense you
want to attack the work right okay that
makes sense
27 okay
all right I'll play this move
6:46
no but actually here you have a big
threat know what is your threat not like
this six will 66 right like that
actually a big threat I cannot allow you
to play this way when you pawn take
checkmate okay so that is true so after
27 maybe you need to play this the
prettiest more but what to do here play
this move
not totally okay I mean it's actually
reasonable 27 it's not a move to be
rejected to be rejected quickly okay
other moves Julian something maybe ah 27
also alright maybe something else
Eugene 5 to finish
Quincy five okay so you have a threat to
play queen 816 do you have also another
threat oh okay so how can black prevent
both threat no this is really important
actually to think that way
how is black going to prevent both of
those threats look e6 exactly okay what
white will play there I mean we want to
learn how to think how to calculate so
we are okay king 87 yeah that is true no
this you know as opposed to the previous
puzzles that were very very forcing move
like immediately capture and get your
idea or capture capture and just end up
being up material I mean okay there are
no captures in this position there are
no there's not anything immediate it's
winning something but what about Queen
g5 so if we don't have any checks or
captures we should be looking at threats
something that is going to lead you to
winning material so there are two major
threats for white one it is quite simple
to see forking they're broken the king
let a simple one but the second one is
tiny twig here it's to play Queen eight
six and from there we would like to play
Queen g7 checkmate and the big problem
is that let's say I'd like to move this
work white is threatening Queen g7
checkmate
they cannot cover this square because
the knight will capture it and you
cannot capture the night because the
Queen is undefended so that's why in
this position well there's really one
move that we'll be able to defend the
Queen and protect will get the book out
actually there's another move dude this
move is also legal because now if Queen
here the King
go out but white is winning here by
playing Knight f6 attacking the work and
the second 20 is 97 [ __ ] their king
in the Queen so it's anyway going to
cost black a decent amount of material
alright so okie 6 yeah now very
important to see our forcing moves check
black is one move check ok it might be
difficult for people that know that
never seen those patterns but when we
see the patterns and no patterns which
is beauty part of calculation they just
make everything so fast you don't need
to think about it you just know ok I can
force the King to move to death square
and then I'm going to give check and
then checkmate so it's white checkmating
like in this puzzle not really is white
forcing to win material actually yes by
the move Queen g5 that starts with just
starting with a big with a big threat
okay so in any position and we will do
more and more no we will either see if
we have captures or threat now puzzle
and those two are okay how about this
one
all right someone's going to tell me
what to play here other than whatever
whatever is going on that table black to
play hey I should flip the board be nice
so the big question is finding well
finding targets in right position if you
are blank if you will find the target
then you will find the right move things
that are not defined there things that
can be under attack things that cannot
easily be defended and so on
yes it looked like half raising the hand
Reika I'll take it
bishop but he will take black to play
right but white will take the be shot
and if the bishop will go back it came
from there right so okay plus it doesn't
have to take right okay so it's not
going to be that move I mean let's think
about whatever you want pieces parts
that are not defended in whites position
well let's ask this is the knight on a
five defended or not
first question anything some mysterious
unseen power defending this night
nothing right no so the night is not
defended now what about this pawn is
this pawn defended if the strong
defended
now you have now so so consequence on
what wanna take it one defend the right
I agree
well it's defended by the King under
attack by the bishop so it's really not
defended right basically may be defended
would be something like plus one to the
defender all right so there are five
attacking pieces and five defenders zero
so it's not defended right like capture
basically it means if you will bring one
more defender you're going to win it so
the night is not defended and the point
is not defended so how can we find a
move to attack both of them
right
anyone here studied geometry right
geometry don't like geometry trying my
goodness that sophisticated one okay so
if we will here see I will I will show
you my mighty skills my mighty geometry
skills okay now what how do we how do
you cancel those arrows do like forever
here this oh not going to work all right
but we will do this so this is a night
okay so how about this this is our
diagonal amazing Julian respect so this
is our night okay this is our diagonal
callable how it works right credible so
this square can maybe go here oops and
go here no but it's really really
important to find pieces that are
undefended and how to attack them
here you go pieces of thread so like is
threatening now kind of checkmate now
you get to in a porno no but of course
it's wrong right I mean by the way this
is okay another topic just for you
but this is winning a night right you
you will see us about plenty of take h2
we'll see about that
but no just two threads right you want
to take here going to take here and kind
of going to win the game by the way
bishop take is actually what does what
does it mean it means that you saw the
idea but play the wrong
play the wrong way it's still winning
upon that's actually true well what does
it mean it means that VP you have seen
their connection between the e5 square
to h2 but instead that's an interesting
straight line don't know how it came but
the queen is attacking the knight
somehow okay now let it be this way okay
let's see let's see if this make it a
bit more straight line that's more
straight alright but you wanna pawn
where you could have win could have won
a knight but seriously this this topic
of finding pieces that are undefended no
is huge
let's see if we let's see if we can have
something exactly like that undefended
pieces let's make it this position okay
what black play so we will do exactly
the same thing we'll think about
squirrels that maybe can be under attack
pieces pawns kings whatever and see how
we can do it
you know
the other way was simply giving you my
whatever face expressions thousand face
expression to show amazement shocked
well what would you play in this world
so what do you would you play in this
maybe I missed something now you scare
me yes I thought I thought I thought if
I put a cap right that is that is a
Looney Tunes but from Looney Tunes
no seriously like what what what what a
collection I mean no seriously I'm going
to speak with your math geometry teacher
in school like what's going on you like
you know you draw some lines you connect
some point boom there and that's right I
mean okay here dude look right right
under attack ones defended ones and
their attack ones defend it ones
okay well you know here boom boom right
so ah no but Quincy five is winning
because same thing right it's
threatening checkmate and straightening
the rule and the thing is we know dude I
told you you're very good player and you
know that and it was actually really
nice the piece you gave me so very cool
in but you know looking at the immediate
capture it's just an instinct and it's
wrong that's why the other one was
immediate for you not because it was the
right thing look if you thought
correctly seriously think about that you
would have said that in this position
let's see the previous position no it's
actually really interesting you know I
thought that this one this is
be somewhat easier for in the eighties
but the concept so so what Julian said
in this position black to play would be
said yeah okay so because you
immediately wanted to think about
capture alright so you said okay it's in
the idea in second I know that so I will
take take and play this move and I'm
going to win material check work so
you're going to take a pawn in a walk
six points today give a knight three you
win something but what you should have
said is oh the G Phi square is
connecting the king and the rook Knight
take H three is the way to get there if
you had said that here then dude then
this position would have been much
easier it's not night h3 that is the
heart of the idea it is the g5 square
and the connection between g5 the rook
to the king right okay
so 25 is winning and once again seeing
two well two spots that are not defended
whether it is H two your g1 or d8 now
this is how winning material happens in
a game it's not if your opponent plays
they move you just go and take it well
that happens at very low levels but at
higher levels you want to connect
something yes
he pushes Jeep on motoki but but why do
you bother here first
why to bother here for example close up
you know I was analyzing I was analyzing
with Nakamura in the sink filled cup and
know at some point he said like is game
against cars in here so I looked at that
why to bother friend of mine like
completely fell in love which is like
idea of why to bother which means ok
it's pointless in some way to play some
position this is really important to
understand when I say why to bother it
means let's say that I just play
whatever let's say I just take ok what's
the problem what what what's the problem
you know what I will go more let's say
that the king was here that's it and now
you can take the knight
ok so what you're telling me is this oh
you only want two points of material and
not three or four but but this is that
exactly the discussion that is why to
bother I don't care you know if I'm
winning completely winning totally
winning
don't care right it's like how was you
know since Carson spoke about Seinfeld
life I will do the same like in one of
me I think the first episode when they
are in the driver is saying well is it
you know don't overdraw it like he's
waiting and spinning and you know 'ti
you know what the jury tell George
even my says there is no such a thing
over dry like dead there is not
something over dead in see their dead or
not it's either dry or not it's so
correct right it's dried to drive if
it's not dry so it's the same thing yeah
you can say winning completely winning
but it's winning so we're not going to
over dry over the door over winner white
to play
oh I've seen it yes China
you
no no okay well then very good what we
are doing here
whatever UCF these days what our UCF
rating these days 1700 yeah that's what
I remembered but I had to question
myself saying that you don't see that oh
man
used to be
no but actually seriously you should see
that quite easily
like now no joke like it means it means
we need to do way more those positions
known okay you know here comes someone
annoying me in that sense to tell you
that you need to do that no we will have
someone else that find the answer Julian
other than you it's and if we have to
stay until 3:30
we will mmm no no coffee
many idea Nathan well we need some I
mean this is more difficult but you need
some vision I mean the part of
visualizing the position is important
here so let's see the material is kind
of equal white are some pretty pair of
bishops but quite equal other than that
this work this work right here ah
looking at the work I'm looking at the
work is under attack once and
potentially right potentially under
attack twice right by which piece the d1
look so let's say let's say okay let's
stop let's say that the position was
like this make it easier this was the
position oh yeah right
easy why because okay you just have a
basic discovered check check and you're
going to take it really it's quite funny
the disposition is maybe not totally
clear because white King is weak but in
principle that's what you will play and
then take the roof right okay so the
idea of connecting the work with the
work with the bishop moving is out there
new okay so now in our list of false
moves it has to be upon the right in our
list of false move well what are our
forcing moves check capture and threat
okay in the hierarchy of threat okay
which which threat is going to be the
main one no what no in general which
threat
in general forget about this position
what a computer go crazy here
checkmate yes
so checkmate is is first trait that we
want to see right checkmate attacking
the Queen and some material right
alright so if the key was on 87 this
would have been just easy discovery but
if you take here what are you really
threatening ah videotape zoom and I can
address you have the edges okay I'll put
it on my Facebook homepage you know like
everyone that that's nice nice
economical idea right you're going to
give 13 points to get six that but
that's what he said when I take take on
f5 and take on da but no seriously
by the way Natan isn't it exactly the
same as you've seen the idea but just
not the way just not the right move
order no that that says no so if we take
on eight seven no what what we have you
know just getting in checkmate here so
the opponent cannot say oh I want to
take the rook I want to move here I want
to move there no those are our two spots
that are undefended no but okay you know
at least you will go home today and
maybe maybe I'll be nice and I will even
recommend you some books to do and maybe
this embarrassment will not repeat
itself but just going to win the game
here take and take on the eight so what
you know no checkmate but white winning
material right by forcing forcing you
know those actually actually you know
it's you know we're supposed to do
strategic ideas and so on but before all
the strategic things no calculating
correctly stand a bit more important
okay this one I really like
why to play
you see it think so alright don't see it
think so I'm certain you don't see
so Nathan what's your idea just tell me
wait they did not a very promising start
after you said you seen it 95 and if I
take my take with a pawn not going to
work not working all right
base of tech d6 no I take
and if I move not here yeah and this
joke I do I go here okay so a yes okay
Quincy five
okay so every so we clearly see this
right we see there we potentially aiming
at the Queen wine we just well it will
happen every time you see Oconee Queen
on same file something to look at and
those to know which words I am allowed
even to use if it's on YouTube probably
not the ones I'm thinking but those two
kids out there now yeah it's locked
young brilliant smart kids out there
well the one has sacrificed like Mad Men
on 87 and then maybe potentially get the
bishop and find themselves with the
night down in all lines or even
something like for example just so you
see 95 and then okay you can maybe move
the bishop let's say no I take the Queen
and this right but here I can just take
take and mourn quite a lot of material
right like Luke Knight Bishop like Mamma
Mia a lot for a coin right so that's not
so cool so basically even if you win the
Queen but you pay too much
not just is a game of so this material
game how much you going to pay for how
much you want to get most of the time
okay so all those immediate capsules are
not working but capsules are not working
and checks are not working let's see if
we have any threat that can make it
happen okay do we have a checkmate
threat no it plus it's not gun it can we
attack the Queen so all of how what the
sort of means but what happened to c4 is
suggested see flow before the c-4
attacking the Queen okay so what's the
problem just goes Queen c5 and now I
know that you're going to allow me to
sleep peacefully tonight because you
will suggest the right move right so c4
is okay now yes very exciting
oh yes slowly no pressure but before I'm
just going to take okay I want to kill
you but maybe I'll have to okay how can
we attack the Queen another way yeah and
you say 93 it's the right move but
obviously not with the right idea what
have you done now with my beast way yes
you open the file know what so basically
by playing to SuperDuper foster knows by
doing which one we'll both of them
attacking the Queen right now when you
attack a your opponent Queen really like
99% he probably has to move the Queen
like really okay 97 whatever something
like that like very very randomly there
can be something more powerful for
example a check which is of course
forcing move oh it check me thread
something that basically will allow him
not to move the Queen but you can force
it that's really important and now it's
raining take take in this idea a in the
game this happen in the game black took
and black law's okay of course
practically this was the right decision
yes two pieces for a queen some play but
is down just too much material and lost
but the important thing of thinking in
that way okay false moves check captures
if not how can I create threat and what
is my goal it was clear that the goal is
to get something on the deef a some
discover now okay so see forcing way to
to get it and actually actually a very
decent way no just to do puzzles like
the puzzles in any
any level like from super beginners
intermediate probably you too can do
some better puzzles and without
mentioning names and probably better use
of chest time would be to get a decent
broken like serious we solve the put on
a put puzzle on a position not move the
pieces think preferably not suggesting
move after 30 seconds and so on other
than most CS things I'm saying other
than doing other things so that was tiny
bit of our false thinking process checks
captures mainly intermediate move